happy to have Charlie hauled me
northwestern forward on his dad Brad
Hall will join us coming up in a little
bit how's morale there Charlie morale is
pretty great honestly I think I think
after the game after the Gonzaga game it
was a little rough but we all are pretty
happy about what we accomplished this
season and about how it all went so I
think morale is pretty high and we're
excited to get back to work how fun was
the ride
oh I mean almost indescribable fun it
was obviously something no one has ever
done before at Northwestern so none of
us had ever experienced we didn't really
know what to expect but you know the way
the campus reacted and all the fans and
the everything that was going on was
just so incredibly exciting and to be
there and experience it and actually win
a game which was great I don't think
anyone was really expecting us to win a
game so to do that was really really
surreal it was really fun what was the
locker room like after that win against
Mandy I mean I think it was probably the
most excited we ever I say the only
comparable time is when we beat Michigan
and the buzzer that was another time
where our locker room was just over the
moon but we were just incredibly excited
and also I think we felt like we we
deserved that you know we didn't want to
go to the tournament to just go to the
tournament and just be there we wanted
to make some noise and so we did what we
said we were going to do so I thought
there was a little bit of it was a
gratifying win as well given the family
tree there with your father being very
funny and your mom being very funny
more pressure for you to be funny or be
a good basketball player oh good
question I'd say I'd say a pretty decent
amount of pressure for both obviously
I'm not a non-core guy and I think at
the tournament there is obviously a
little more pressure for the guys that
do play so if I'm able to alleviate some
of that which is sort of what I was able
to do all season I think that job does
become actually a little more important
so maybe being funny actually became a
little more key to my role although
still
obviously being a good basketball player
and being good on scout team and stuff
was also important but definitely I
think the ability to let my guys loosen
up a little bit was became a little more
important do you do play-by-play when
you're on the bench
I don't although that's a good idea
maybe I'll start doing that snarky
play-by-play guy Charlie I think that's
what we do do you get more of your is
your sense of humor from your dad or
your mom I'd say that my the jokes I
make are more similar to the jokes my
dad makes although the things I find
funny are is more similar to my mom
let's bring in your dad Brad Hall the
actor comedian writer producer married
Julia louis-dreyfus back in 1987 Brad
good morning thanks for joining us good
morning how describe that feeling when
you and Julia sit down to watch a game
they and you know even these tournament
games like what is it like as parents
watching this knowing Charlie's probably
not getting in but you're still watching
the results of your alma mater I it was
we did not expect to be quite so
pathetically involved and by the end by
the time that they were in the
tournament if you'd let us we would have
just been weeping all day the whole
thing was so much fun and Charlie was so
happy with his role on the team and the
team was so spectacular you got to
understand that when we were there this
was not a team that was going any
tournaments they could barely get the
Big Ten Tournament for us just nostalgic
ly it was great but moreover through
Charlie we got to meet all these kids
that are on this team and all the
parents and this is an extraordinary
group of young men I got to say it's
whatever coach Collins is doing to
recruit he's recruiting really humble
smart hard-working funny kids so for us
the whole thing turned out to be just a
spectacular ride now your wife makes her
living being on camera and you know
you're gonna be on camera but this has
to be a different feeling for her to be
on camera as just a mom wanting to show
up there to cheer and even you is the
dad
yeah I think she forgets completely that
there's any chance that she might be on
camera and there is no fan who is
screaming louder or and she actually
understands the game pretty well now -
when we first went Charlie first started
playing when he was really little she
couldn't care less about basketball but
you know you go to enough of these games
over the years and through high school
and Club and everything and now she's a
real expert Michele she'll tell you
exactly what she's thinking and she is
certainly telling the reps what she was
thinking in the Gonzaga game that's for
sure Charlie dear parents ever embarrass
you during a game you know they haven't
yet in college although I would say that
they didn't do so in in Middle School in
high school occasionally only because
there were a little less fans so they
were a little more audible but not
because you can hear your mom right
I mean I would say yeah a matter I mean
she she gets nervous during games and
when she gets nervous she gets louder
give me give me an impression there
Charlie of mom
an impression of mom I would although I
think I would maybe break your speaker
it's okay we'll ride the levels there
okay here we go something along those
lines
you're forgetting the expletive really
mom will drop some unbelievable Charlie
your athleticism comes from mom or dad
I'd say probably dad I don't know
although I don't know if my my scores I
mean I'm not kidding that's true I mean
she's tiny but but her mom's family has
really big guys I mean six six types and
I'm the tallest in my family and I'm
only 62 so I think her that the height
comes from comes from the bowl from the
bowls I mean from the both side of
family Lefevers the pressure was
Saturday Night Live - this is there any
kind of parallel there at live tv live
basketball watching something where you
knew how Saturday Night Live was gonna
end you don't know how a basketball game
is going to end
though you never really knew how
certainly doubt but yeah you know it's
very tense it's so exciting I mean when
a game like the Gonzaga game when they
had such a miserable first half and then
they showed such grit and determination
and coming back and it became just so I
don't know if you could tell on
television but man in the arena that was
a game that was winnable all of a sudden
and you just can't believe it it's like
a dream and but really the thing is that
Ford we're just happy that our kid is
happy that turns out to be the
overwhelming emotion that that he's so
happy in college that that just makes us
so happy the fact that they're winning
just as icing on the cake so Charlie
were two years in and we haven't scored
yet right correct okay but he's leading
the I believe that per minute he's
leading the entire NC to a and rebound
yes this is this is probably true I
haven't checked up on that statistic but
I would assume that that's true do you
keep track of your points in warm-ups no
although I do try and the thing I do in
warmups is I try and dunk as early as I
can
earlier I got a warm up for a bit to
dunk but the earlier I can do that the
better we seem to play so that that's a
little superstition do you spend you're
sending a message to the opposition when
they look and I go holy Charlie Hall is
he's dunking exactly you know oh what
are you what are you studying by the way
at Northwestern I'm an art EVs major
which is I'm a film major that which is
fun so we're going down this road with
mom and dad
yes hopefully in front of the camera
behind the camera you know I don't
really know but I think probably behind
the camera I'm not a very good actor but
I haven't really decided that yet I
guess that could change but I'm
definitely leaning towards behind the
camera with directing or writing or
something like that you have any advice
for him there Brent absolutely none
whatsoever
does mom get involved in this or is this
just a Charlie's on his own yeah you
can't help yourself get involve of it
but Charlie's got his own voice and his
own so
stuff he wants to do and you were
thrilled whatever he decides I'd be a
very funny doctor or a lawyer to Charlie
I I'd like to I'd like to update here
next year when you're on the bench doing
snarky play-by-play and and when you
score cuz you will score next year I
will put the pressure on Collins coach
Collins to run a play for you damn it
yeah right we need just a little
pressure yeah and it's not gonna be a
three it might be like a foul line
extended 15-footer but I just think it's
gonna be pure I really do Charlie
they're gonna be there's gonna be
posters I mean it's gonna be emotional
it'll yeah could we make a Rudy moment
out of this though Brad as talent is you
and your wife are could is there some
way that the northwestern kids get ready
to turn in their jerseys because they're
angry that Charlie hasn't been able to
score basket that's I'm working on that
we're gonna do that I think that's very
quality minute I like that well we're
high like that Charlie don't let us down
I'd like to hear an update next year
okay absolutely good luck with that Brad
great to talk to you thank you for
joining us all right thanks so much Brad
and Charlie Hall dad and son I like that
little snarky play-by-play over there a
little microphone on him be good I think
we're good
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience